>> Katie: DEMOCRATS AND
TEACHERS UNION WITH THE
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION 1.3 MILLION
STUDENTS HAVE LEFT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC, SO FAR BEHIND IT COULD
TAKE THEM TWO YEARS TO CATCH UP
ACADEMICALLY.
AND RIGHT BEFORE THE START OF A
NEW YEAR NOW A NATIONWIDE
TEACHER SHORTAGE, BUT TEACHERS
UNIONS AND LIBERAL LAWMAKERS
PUSHING HIS LOCKDOWN POLICY IS
AND ARE HOPING THAT PEOPLE WILL
FORGET ALL ABOUT IT.
>> BUT FIRST THEY MUST REOPEN
SAFELY.
WE KNOW THAT KIDS NEED IN-PERSON
LEARNING AND THAT REMOTE
INSTRUCTION IS NO SUBSTITUTE FOR
IT, BUT IT HAS TO BE SAFE!
>> BOTTOM LINE, LEARNING IS
NONNEGOTIABLE, BUT NEITHER IS
SAFETY.
>> WE ESTIMATE AT THIS MOMENT
THAT IT IS OVER 90% OF OUR
STUDENTS, YOU CAN ARGUE THAT IT
IS CLOSER THAN 95, 97% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE LIKELY TO START THE
SCHOOL YEAR WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING.
>> Katie: AS WE GET CLOSER
THAN MY TERMS DEMOCRATS ARE
TRYING TO WIN BACK PARENTS BY
TALKING ABOUT EVERYTHING BUT
EDUCATION.
SO GREAT IT, DON'T YOU THINK
THAT MORE PEOPLE WILL LEAVE THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM IF THEY
COULD, BUT THEY ARE TRAPPED?
>> Greg: IT PEOPLE ACTUALLY
SAW WHAT THE TEACHERS WERE DOING
WITH THEIR KIDS.
THE WEIRD FLIP WAS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS RALLY AND PRIDE WAS
WHAT ABOUT THE CHILDREN?
THAT'S ALL YOU HEARD, WHAT ABOUT
THE CHILDREN?
CHILDREN ON THE FUTURE NOW IT IS
WHAT ABOUT THE TEACHERS UNIONS?
WHAT ABOUT THE DRAG PERFORMERS!
THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
PERFORM IN CLASSES!
THE RIGHTS OF THE NONBINARY
INSTRUCTOR TO EXPLAIN THEIR
GENDER PREFERENCES TO A TODDLER.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS THE DE
FACTO PARTY FOR THE PARENTS.
WHAT WOULD YOU RATHER ALIGN WITH
A VIEW I KIDS?
I DON'T HAVE THEM, SO I'M JUST
SPEAKING FOR THE PARENTS, WOULD
YOU RATHER BE A PART OF A PARTY
THAT ONCE YOUR KIDS TAUGHT OR
SHUT DOWN, LOCKED DOWN OR
TARGETING PARENTS AS DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS THAT ACTUALLY SUPPORT
YOUR PARENTS?
ONLY ONE PARTY IS THE
REPUBLICANS THAT BASICALLY
PARENTS ARE FREE MONEY ON THE
TABLE ON THE REPUBLICAN SHOULD
GET UP THERE AND GRAB IT AND
TALK ABOUT THE NUMBERS OF THESE
KIDS NOT BEING IN SCHOOL, THE
DAMAGES TO THEIR PSYCHE, THE
OBSESSION WITH SEXUALITY, THE
DESIRE FOR SURGERY TO CORRECT
TODDLER BEHAVIOR, IS AN
JOE BIDEN TALKING ABOUT
BREAST IMPLANTS FOR MEN.
THE DEMOCRATS IN A WAY HAVE
TURNED CHILDREN INTO
EXPERIMENTAL SUBJECTS THROUGH
BIOLOGY, THEIR GENDER, THROUGH
EDUCATION, SO REPUBLICANS NOW
HAVE TO BE THE RESCUE SQUAD.
THEY HAVE TO BE THE PARENTS
PARTY.
I THINK IT IS KIND OF HAPPENING,
BUT THEY ARE USUALLY A LITTLE
SLOW ON THESE THINGS.
>> Katie: SO KENNEDY, A NUMBER
OF REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS WHO
DECIDED THAT ACTUALLY WE CAN
AFFORD FOR PEOPLE TO TAKE THEIR
KIDS OUT OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
STILL PAYING PROPERTY TAXES, SO
WE WILL ALLOW THEM TO TAKE THAT
MONEY AND PUT IT TOWARDS THE
EDUCATION OF THEIR CHOICE WHICH
OPEN UP A NUMBER OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTS.
>> Kennedy: AND THAT'S WHAT
THE SCHOOL CHOICE MOVEMENT IS
ALL ABOUT IS ACTUALLY HAVING THE
CHOICE, IT'S ONE THING, SEND A
PRIVATE, MOST KIDS CAN'T AFFORD
$30,000 A YEAR FOR PER STUDENT,
BUT IF IT WERE SOMETHING LIKE
SIX OR 7,000 YEAR AND THAT'S
WHAT WE PAID IN TAXES FOR YOUR
KIDS, THEN PLACES LIKE ARIZONA
WHERE THE GOVERNORS ARE SIGNING
LEGISLATION THAT GOES THROUGH
THE STATE LEGISLATURE THAT
ALLOWS PARENTS TO MAKE THOSE
CHOICES.
IF YOU WANT YOUR KIDS TO AS GREG
SAID HAVE LECTURES ABOUT GENDER
PREFERENCE AND EVERYTHING, THEN
YOU CAN SEND YOUR KIDS TO SCHOOL
LIKE THAT.
THAT'S FINE, IF THAT'S WHAT YOU
WANT, THEY WILL DO A BANG-UP
JOB.
IF YOU WANT YOUR KIDS TO BE AN
ENVIRONMENT IN SCHOOL IN PERSON
WHERE THEY ARE LEARNING MATH AND
SCIENCE AND READING, THEN MAYBE
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
CHOICE.
AND I HOPE THAT THERE ARE MORE
LAWMAKERS AND MORE STATES THAT
ALLOW PARENTS TO DO THAT,
BECAUSE TEACHERS UNIONS
OVERPLAYED THEIR HAND.
THEY ARE TERRIBLE THINGS THAT
PARENTS WILL NOT STAND THE
WITHDRAWAL OF AFGHANISTAN AND
WHAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS HAVE DONE
THE KIDS IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
THEY WERE EXPOSED TO DURING THE
PANDEMIC, THEY WILL NOT FORGET
THAT AS MUCH AS THEY SEE SMOKE
AND MIRRORS TO TRY TO MAKE IT GO
AWAY.
>> Katie: SO WHILE THEY WERE
UP THERE TALKING ABOUT THINGS
HAD TO BE SAFE AND THEY WANTED
TO REOPEN, BUT THEY HAD TO TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES FIRST RATHER
THAN THINKING ABOUT THE
LONG-TERM EFFECTS OF KEEPING
CHILDREN OUT OF SCHOOLS
BASICALLY HOLDING THE TAXPAYERS
HOSTAGE FOR MORE MONEY THAT IS
SPENT INAPPROPRIATELY AND WE
KNOW THAT THEY BASICALLY DONATE
TO DEMOCRATS.
>> Jesse: SO IT IS A MONEY
LAUNDERING OPERATION, SAYING WE
CAN'T TEACH UNTIL THE CLASS
ROOMS ARE CLEAN, SO SEND THE
CASH, THEY DID TAKE THE CASH AND
DON'T OPEN UP THE CLASSROOMS AND
SEND IT BACK IN TERMS OF
DONATIONS AND ALL OF THE TEST
SCORES GO DOWN ON THE TEACHERS
UNION SAYS THE SAME THING AND
SAY SEE, THIS IS WHY WE NEED
MORE MONEY SO THAT WE CAN HIRE
MORE TEACHERS AND DONATE MORE,
AND THEN THERE IS A DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN THE WHITE SCORES ON THE
BLACK SCORES AND THEY SAY, SEE,
THIS IS WHY WE NEED CRT, BECAUSE
IT IS A RACIST SYSTEM AND THEN
ALL OF THE STUDENTS COME BACK
FROM THE LOCKDOWN
PSYCHOLOGICALLY DAMAGED AND THEY
SAY, SEE, THIS IS WHY WE NEED TO
PUSH CISGENDER PROPAGANDA ON
THESE KIDS, AND ALL OF THE
PARENTS ARE LIKE WAIT A SECOND,
I DON'T LIKE THIS AT ALL IN THE
TEACHERS UNION SAYS THIS IS OUR
CHILD AND THEN HAVE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SLAP TERRACE TAGS
ON THEM.
I DON'T THINK REPUBLICANS WILL
DO ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
IT KIND OF REMINDS YOU THAT
MORTGAGE MELTDOWN IN 2008 WHEN
IT WAS LIKE PUT THESE GUYS IN
JAIL FOR WALL STREET A SINGLE
WALL STREET BANKER THAT TOOK UP
THIS PAPER AND PROSECUTED
NOBODY, SAME WITH DR. FAUCI, HE
IS NOT CRIMINALLY INVESTIGATED.
JANUARY 6 DID NOT DAMAGE THE
COUNTRY IS MUCH AS THESE LOCK
DOWNS, BUT WE HAVE HEARING AFTER
HEARING AFTER HEARING A NO
HEARING ON THE LOCKDOWN.
IF YOU ARE A PUBLIC-POLICY
PERSON AND YOU'RE PUSHING PUBLIC
POLICY THAT IS KILLING PEOPLE,
THAT IS DESTROYING PEOPLE'S
CIVIL RIGHTS AND HURTING A
GENERATION OF KIDS GRADES, YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE PROSECUTED
CRIMINALLY.
>> Katie: JUST CUT, THE WORLD
BANK ESTIMATES BECAUSE OF THE
LEARNING AND THE LOCKDOWN, THEY
LOST $17 TRILLION OF EARNING
POTENTIAL FOR THE GENERATION
THAT WAS KEPT OUT OF SCHOOL, SO
GIVEN THE DAMAGE THAT THE
TEACHERS UNION HAS DONE TO
ITSELF, WHAT IS THE DEMOCRAT
SOLUTION TO MAKING UP FOR LOST
TIME AND ALSO TRYING TO GET KIDS
BACK TO PUBLIC SCHOOL GIVEN THE
ENVIRONMENT?
>> Jessica: I THINK THAT
DEMOCRATS NEED TO TALK ABOUT THE
AMERICAN RESCUE ACT DOLLARS THAT
WENT TO THE SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN SPENT AND BE VERY CLEAR
THAT THEY WANT TO SEE IT GO INTO
SUMMER SCHOOL RESOURCES,
AFTER-SCHOOL TUTORING, MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES, EVERYTHING TO
TRY AS BEST WE CAN TO PROTECT
THE KIDS THAT ARE STILL IN THE
SYSTEM AND THEN A NATIONAL
CAMPAIGN TO THE 1.3 MILLION KIDS
MAN IN SCHOOL ANYMORE TO GET
THEM BACK AS THEY CAN.
BACK IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
SOME KIDS ARE NOT IN SCHOOL
ANYMORE, WE DID LOSE KIDS.
JUST DISAPPEARED AND THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTING FOR THEM ESPECIALLY
ON THE OTHER SIDE, SO WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT THIS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
VIRGINIA BECAUSE OF THE
EDUCATION ISSUE AND HE RAN ONTO
BIFURCATE WHAT HE TALKED ABOUT,
THIS PROBLEM, NOT CRT OR THE
DRAG STORY HOUR, BECAUSE HE SAID
THERE ARE MODERATES ON BOTH A
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN SIDE, WE
ARE NOT BUYING THIS, BUT THEY DO
CARE THAT THEIR KIDS WEAR MASKS,
THEY DO CARE THAT THEIR KIDS ARE
AT HOME, SO HERE ARE THE PIECES
INTERVIEWING DEMOCRATIC VOTERS
ON WHAT HAPPENED IN NEW JERSEY
AND THIS IS THE ONLY ISSUE WHERE
THEY WERE PERSUADABLE ON,
BECAUSE THEY SAID I SUPPORT THE
DEMOCRATIC AGENDA EXCEPT FOR THE
FACT THAT THIS HAPPENED TO MY